what's up everybody welcome okay so the
plan for tonight we're starting with
some tactics and then i believe there's
an hourly rapid arena starting in 54
minutes so the plan is simple boys we're
doing tactics for the next 50 minutes
good warm up and then we're gonna win
the hourly rapid arena
tactics we've got rook takes b2
which could be a move
knight takes c4
knight takes c4 this queen takes a5
right and i don't see the follow-up if
you take then you lose your rook rook
takes b2 king takes b2 then knight takes
c4 that doesn't look like it works
either watch tickar vs anish before
watching a bit of the chiefs versus
charger game oh right it is thursday
night which means that there is football
going on do you guys know about
scorigami nfl
scorigami.com i'm pretty sure it's
dot-com
basically a very brief overview due to
the very unique scoring system of
american football some scores are much
more likely to occur like a score of
four to zero is very rare because the
only way to get that one team has to get
two safeties and the other team has to
not score at all intro scorigami the
most common nfl scores 20 to 17 the
winning side scores 20 and the losing
side scores 17. if you look at all of
the nfl games played in history sort by
first game the first nfl game with a
final score of 31 to 5 happened in 2021
arnold's versus the houston texans
october 24th is the first 31 to 5 score
in nfl history where's another one from
2021 45 to 30. never happened before
2021 the colts versus the jets you can
see you know all the upcoming games you
can see chiefs versus chargers there's a
point 91 percent chance of scoring that
basically means there's a 0.91 chance
that though they will get a score a
final score that has never happened
before okay that's nfl scoring and you
can you can check that out if you like
football yeah kind of crazy that those
scores had like never happened before
and they still are happening like there
was like six or seven scorigamis in the
2020 season it still happens there's
been like at least three or four in the
2021 season just so far
it was agonizing seeing non-chess
content
we do we do
quite a bit of non-chess content here i
mean i like to just talk about
whatever's on my mind last stream we
were talking about philosophy i wanted
to bring up something about solipsism
that i didn't bring up i didn't remember
it until like the next day so now that i
have another chance to bring it up you
know i'm going to tell you guys so
solipsism case anyone who's not here for
the tuesday stream is the belief that
you are the only conscious being in the
entire universe it's a non-falsifiable
theory right there's no way to disprove
that because everything that exists for
you exists inside of your mind and
there's no way you can get around that
filter because in order to interpret
sensory inputs every sensory input goes
through a filter and that is the central
nervous system it's your brain so how do
you know that you are not the only
conscious being in the entire universe
there's no way to disprove that and
there's another theory it kind of goes
hand in hand with solipsism it's called
the dream argument and it does not have
anything to do with the minecraft
youtuber
[Laughter]
although that would be pretty funny if
it did
the dream argument states that people
have probably you at one point have
experienced dreams where you're dreaming
and you don't realize it's a dream until
you wake up most people i think most
people have probably experienced that at
least one time kind of an
additional piece of evidence to this
argument is you guys have seen videos of
people like wearing vr headsets in their
living room and then like diving into
their tvs
right that's just like an additional
piece of evidence that i thought of to
this dream argument but i haven't even
presented the argument yet which is if
that happens a lot of times you don't
know you're dreaming i think most of the
time you don't know you're dreaming so
how do you know you're not just dreaming
right now you could say well when i go
to sleep that i know i'm dreaming then
so i must not be dreaming now like
there's consistency
but
there's no way to prove it you can't
prove that you're not dreaming right now
there's no way
because everything goes through
your mind the central nervous system
so that is a
daily philosophy discussion okay
now that we've talked about american
football and solipsism and the dream
argument
let's do some chess
okay listen we can get back above 3 100.
we can do it
we can make what the frick is this
development dude what has black been
doing all game what are you doing
this is like a 200 level game not 200
200 level rating
the pawn only challenge what is what is
this guy doing
chess.com sometimes
they will pull positions
from all of the games that anyone has
played sometimes those games will be
from really really weak players and
sometimes the tactics in those games
sometimes tactics in those games happen
that are really really high rated
tactics so then you get positions like
this in the tactics trainer
with
like this position would never happen in
a game between
two skilled chess players because
what is black doing with their pieces it
just would never happen
but it's like i have to deal with these
positions as a 3100 rated tactician
white has just hung their night their
knight was hanging they had a
opportunity to save that but you know
they didn't play knight f1 like a normal
person so okay the obvious move is queen
takes h2
and now g takes f3 okay i think g takes
f3 is a pretty obvious next move here so
i think it forces king takes f3 like
maybe rook h3 it could actually be rook
h3 yeah cause i don't actually see a
super good follow up after gtx f3 king
takes f3 like there's d takes e4 that's
another check but i'm thinking it's rook
h3 why would paul probably play rook h1
queen takes g3 check the problem there
king e3 bishop h6 wins the queen rook h3
rook h1 takes there is king f1 on king
f1 though there's actually also bishop
a6 check that move looks pretty good
white doesn't have any good blocks white
doesn't have to play rook h1 they could
play something like king e3 but then we
could play rook takes g3 i'm playing
rook h3 because i don't i don't see a
better alternative i played queen f4
which makes sense because you're
defending your g pawn bishop h6 there's
queen takes g4 there's also queen d6 i
do like this move which is e5 because
the bishop protects the pawn so there's
no longer queen takes g4 d takes e5 then
on bishop h6 the queen is actually
trapped so i like this move i'm gonna
play e5
white can open up the center and just
like totally start curb stomping us if
they get two moves but first of all they
have to have material for that to work
so goodbye
queen
bishop h6 rook h1 takes takes
takes followed by takes sorry you take
the rook so that you don't lose your own
rook
looks okay looks okay to me good job
nine point eight percent pass rate
anything under 15
is pretty difficult